o título da palestra porque mandar em pó
é porque hoje em dia o consumo de açaí é
todo mundo só consome é lindo pra fora
do país só congelado dessa forma e sai
muito caro
e nada melhor do que a gente fazer é em
pó que o alimento em pó é muito melhor
do que qualquer tipo de de alimento que
nos integrada isso aí do decorrer da
palestra eu vou falando um pouco e o
brasil sendo o maior produtor de açaí do
do mundo nem amazônia ac com nosso
município aqui a cerca de 200km codajás
também que um dos maiores produtores de
açaí é e nós exportamos sair para todo o
o o mundo inteiro tanto para a europa
como pra no japão é o estados unido eo
açaí virou uma febre nem todo mundo
conhece só saía sair e e e com isso eh
eh sai caro às vezes é mandar esse
produto na forma congelado e também há
um tempo de durabilidade que o açaí
quando se retira da mata
você tem que processar imediatamente por
motivo que se não aí ele a sythex
aumenta e e e estraga logo com o
decorrer do de durante 11 horas ele se
degrada né
então por que não mandar ele em pó
mandando em pó é muito melhor do que
todo esse processo que que é feito hoje
em dia as indústria como são realizadas
nós amazonas nós temos um hábito
cultural de comer essa aí é de várias
maneiras nós aqui do amazonas fetam mão
só o suco pessoal do pará já já misturou
com um pouco de de peixes é com outras
com a
marão agora a febre aqui virou a mistura
com granola castanha então só é uma
maneira que o consumo está a diversa
diversificando cada vez mais ainda o
consumo do a saída mas ninguém tá se
preocupando de fazê lo ele em pó
então eu com o trabalho com essa parte
do laboratório e fiz ele em pó que
depois eu vou passar aqui para todo
mundo
depois eu também né
geralmente quando eu passo eu nunca
devolve aí do que nunca chega de volta
são dois espécie que eu vou falar é são
paulo já saí porque dizer uma quantidade
dessa daí de 60 gramas
você faz um litro de açaí então quer
dizer já não precisa que ela aquela
quantidade tão grande de dividiu de
processamento congelado gastar energia
gente transformou em pó pronto já está
pronto para o consumo
tipo a comida do astronauta nacional
tudo e só come pode valer a próxima é
curto tempo chega lá e hidrata o acordo
tudo é pílula cápsula tenho feito também
muitas cápsulas de açaí tudo importa em
pó e por que tomar açaí nem todo mundo
fala a sair tal é é a sair é muito
importante ele ele é muito rico em
ácidos graxos que nem eu tô falando em
um pouco de oleico que é um ácido graxo
que eleva o colesterol o hdl o bom
colesterol ele tem um elevado no
tradicional o alto teor de tanto de
potássio com o de fibras e e também ele
é muito rico em antocianinas então que
quis antocianina porque tem um potencial
antioxidante muito importante que o a
antocianina as que têm as propriedades
antioxidantes e
inflamatória e o que são essas ante é
essa a distância meninas são grandes
protetores da nossas artérias nem quer
dizer gordura não no nossas artérias
nele e ele age também como estabilização
do açúcar no sangue
então isso é um benefício do açaí que o
iphone apesar de ter um potencial
antioxidante muito alto
ele é um alimento funcional quer dizer é
benéfico à nossa saúde então quem tomar
açaí é muito importante é ele combate
erradicar nível todo mundo sabe que o
radicalismo nós que estamos velhos assim
nada melhor do que consumir os alimentos
da amazônia que são ricos em
antioxidantes e tem também aquele velho
tabu né
o açaí é rico em ferro o açaí eu estudei
a sair de vários municípios são maiores
produtores de da amazônia são na mama
cérebro parar e até o pará é o estado
ali também que no município de tabatinga
benjamim parintins incrível que pareça
incrível que pareça é é o que teve maior
quantidade de ferro foi autazes é pará
pará ficou perdeu pra amazonas viu então
não tem não tem ferro não ferro tem não
aquela quantidade que têm tabelas aí que
diz que tem 11 20 miligramas por 100
gramas não existe
ele tem 1 ponto 2 isso corresponda
micrograma ele tem no máximo 1.2
micrograma em sem grama de pouco essa
pompa e que vocês vão me devolver daqui
a pouco
z então e são dois espécie isso que está
correndo aí com vocês
são dois espécie de açaí uma que é a
precatória
e a outra que é olerácea a precatória é
conseguir chamado o açaí do amazonas que
o açaí solteiro que é aquele açaí que só
dar só um caudilho que chama se une
caule unical nem chama se a sair
solteiro
já o olerácea que é o açaí do pará
esse já é aquele que dá em torcer com
quanto mais você corta mas ele ele vai
nascendo e vai dando muito palmito isso
aqui também tem palmito então tem tudo o
que o outro tem esse é aqui também vi a
maneira o mais tradicional geralmente o
pessoal faz em forma de suco é você pode
consumir em doce e com é tudo uma
maneira que você quiser você consome a
saída é e geralmente nós temos é se
preocupado bastante com esse
processamento de de açaí que o açaí
ele já está contaminado já no próprio pé
quando você pega tiro os cachos de nós
aí para fazer o processamento ele já vem
com contaminação então geralmente quando
retira se o os cachos de açaí é
geralmente nós fazemo lavagem me fazer
ir lá vamos também com hipoclorito que o
famoso todo mundo sabe que aquela água
clorada depois ante a sanitização aí faz
um pequeno cozimento que é o tipo a
pasteurização depois despolpamento
acondicionamento e armazenagem para
depois voltar a ele na secagem
distribuir bandeja que esse é um
processo que eu tô fazendo n pó que
existe tanto como um atomizador que é um
spray drae e existe também
une o finalizador que esse que está
correndo aí com vocês que une o
utilizador em baixa temperatura ea menos
de 80 graus enquanto o atomizador ele
ela é com temperatura 360 ele perde as
propriedades nutricionais
já o com o de oficialização
nós não perdemos a nossa as propriedades
nutricionais que tem nosso aí e depois
de ele vir em pó
o que acontece é que vai ter mais de
vida de do duração as propriedades não
se perde
agora olha o que tem dentro do açaí com
do efeito aquele processo sem fazer toda
ação de indenização então que tem aí tem
bolores e leveduras tem fungos
isso tudo dentro do próprio sair mas não
vamos ficar com medo não que isso aí tem
com tem como tirar isso aí viu tanta
gente pega sair de feira dele que não
tem um bom processamento aí é para essas
coisas aí como resolver o problema
nada melhor do que fazer isso aqui
qualquer um pode fazer dentro da sua
própria casa né
após ter legislação é aquele que você
primeiro fazer um aquecimento e depois
fazer uma imersão ele com um banho de
gelo já viram um pasteurizador e depois
ou faz também fervor em 30 segundos o
também fervura em 60 segundo isso nós
fizemos testes em laboratório os
destruiu tudo isso aí depois que foi
feito tudo isso nós publicamos este
trabalho também e foi erradicado os
microorganismo do do açaí então pode
comer dessa forma com um pegando a
saírem feira que não tem procedência
você chega na sua casa pode fazer de si
mesma coisa antes de consumir colocar na
geladeira faz um processo de
pasteurização a figura e não vai meter
não vai mudar o aroma nem o sabor
aqui é o processo à maneira do consumo
sem risco não se faz a pasteurização ou
de formação
esse aqui é no nosso laboratório que é
um mundial realizado ainda no final e
sair desse jeito e e também isso é como
ficou a diferença do açaí do precatório
e olerácea do amazonas junto para ele
não muda a tonalidade o sabor também é
no sabor é igual o valor nutricional
também é igual e porque eu falei do
aceita que eu falo eu falei do açaí
porque o maior consumo do mundo hoje em
dia todo mundo só só sair só sair mas
nada melhor do que outro nesse caso em
campo campo que eu acabo de me mostrar
pra vocês que também todos os frutos da
amazônia todos eles é fácil em pó e e só
basta hoje tem uma indústria para fazer
o desenvolvimento
outra coisa que também é devido aos seus
benefícios o complemento básico por isso
que eu falei que ia sair porque hoje em
dia o próprio sair
ele é um complemento básico na
alimentação às vezes é até uma
alimentação do ser humano
outro também que a gente sempre fácil
isso aqui todo mundo imagina que seja
isso aqui é tambaqui em pó é tanto aqui
em pó de rede foi imposta e eu fiz ele
em pó
então aí quando eu coloco nem pra fazer
imposta você pode pegar pós-sol retratar
pronto é macau da europa de tampa de
tambaqui
agora está aqui melhor ainda que isso
aqui tá bom o alto valor de proteína e
está em portão aqui em pó e porque em pó
porque não degrada né eu falei e seus
constituintes nutricionais durabilidade
em vida de prateleira na inter safra
sempre vai ter e o produto é nutritivo
inteiramente regional valores e recursos
produtivos da região amazônica é com
novo para o pequeno e médio produtor né
então sempre ele em pó e ele tem o ano
todo eo açaí ele só dá e tem a safra
dele na na época chuvosa
imagina e aqui é o pessoal todo mundo
tomando o caboco a outra coisa é a
criança aqui com 11 também tomando a
sair muito obrigado